bald startet die fußball-bundesliga
wieder und auch diese frage spaltet
deutschland ein wenig ja jetzt mit fans
oder ohne fans bis ihre auffassung volle
stadien wieder das glaube ich ist im
augenblick nicht drin
das ist mein geführten und das als sie
sind dagegen dass abend auch jeder dass
das sehr schwierig ist wir werden das
diskutieren mit den ländern das müssen
die gesundheitsbehörden ihre meinung
dazu entwickeln aber wir können ja nicht
in diese sendung hinein uns diskutieren
und reden über neue risikogebiete und so
tun als wäre nichts los
also wer das gefühl hat die sache sei
abgehakt wir haben schon alles geschafft
der irrt sich und er macht einen
schweren fehler